all right joel
joe where'd you grow up where are you
from originally i'm originally from new
york city i was born in manhattan
um but i was raised a few years in
allentown pennsylvania which is about a
90-minute drive from new york city that
you're in new york now absolutely yeah
uh since 13 years old i've been uh i
came back from allentown pennsylvania
and been here since i'm 35 right now and
tell me about your family growing up
so growing up with my family
unfortunately it wasn't really that good
um
i i find myself now at 35 years old just
learning to um communicate with my
family especially my mother and my
father
uh we have a history of of drug abuse
in my family um and also i was taken
away from my family when i was a child
is why i've been going back and forth
from pennsylvania to new york city
so um it's not really that good with my
relationship but it can get better with
with patience and communication
um i constantly talk to my mom every
single day even this for five or ten
minutes just to see how she's doing
she's 65 years old
um
my father i haven't communicated with
him for over 10 years so i don't really
know what's going on with him
but again you know we had a bumpy bumpy
uh childhood and i found myself going
from house to house from state to state
how would you describe your childhood in
general
besides that um i was a very playful
child um always jokey sense of humor
i had a lot of friends in pennsylvania
which i actually missed
at that time there was a lot of
caucasians in allentown it wasn't as
much as a mixed race that as it is now
in 2022 so we used to always go out and
play like rover manhunt
uh true for dares you know what kids
like to experience and you know um
that's what really stood with me even
when i turned 35 years old i find myself
fascinating about these these
experiences that i had grew up with um
when i was a child and missed it every
single day that you know i think about
it um
and and only
seem to uh watch it on television or
movies and you know so it is a little
heartbreaking um my childhood changed
when i came to new york city i
immediately got caught up with the wrong
group at 13 years old when i ran away
and uh not even four or five months i
was already arrested for
a criminal sale control substance um in
the second degree to undercover cops
from the 46th precinct of the bronx
and um i was too young to be uh sent to
prison obviously i was only 13 so
you know my mom had to come pick me up
but you know at that time my mom still
felt guilty of being taken to
me being taken away so i guess my mom
wasn't really that good of
giving discipline to her child
i guess she feared that will always
bring up the past of telling her you
can't tell me anything but so she never
had a chance or even tried to even
discipline me but accepted my
my bad behaviors
for example when i got released and she
had to pick me up in precinct she'll
tell me to don't sell to the cop you
know instead of smacking me or punishing
me like a parent supposed to do
like a kid is supposed to um have
but um instead
i didn't get that
um
i pretty much had like a friend growing
up in my family
and it just still like that ever since
i'm sorry
you finished school
um
i dropped out of seventh grade again
because i ran away from pennsylvania at
13
and um
i didn't want my mom and my nieces or my
sisters in new york city getting in
trouble for me running away and not
listening to my father and the police
officers in pennsylvania that if i do
run away again they will take everyone
so um
i pretty much kept it quiet until i got
arrested
um for the for the criminal self-control
substance the first time and then i was
forced to go to school
upon release so um
i dropped out at seventh grade and uh i
tried to go back to the school but again
i had i had no no kind of support
or no type of
um structure for a 13 year old child
that really needs to keep pushing him
you know
i was just not capable of making
decisions at 13 years old by myself
unfortunately
um so i just found myself dropping back
out of school and going back to selling
drugs again um the only people that did
accept me whether i was bad or good the
only ones that really um was there for
me that i thought at 13 years old were
my
my bad influence friends
were way older than me i mean i'm 13
they're like in their 20s
and
i just found myself going back there and
dropping back out and my mom and my
family just never found the strength or
the courage to even try to sub uh to
discipline me
you know at 13 years old um
i got arrested again the second time and
i met a woman
that was way older than me
and that's another
uh story
and after that i i got arrested um and
went to juvenile
and then i ended up getting my ged in
the shock program
um and graduated and it's why i catch
myself now especially which is not good
it's weird
of dreaming
and
thinking about this boot camp that i've
been at
because um
unfortunately these are the only people
that helped me
um unfortunately these were the only
people that
didn't give up on me
um as much as i i i was a i was not
listening
um
they they disciplined me to the point
where i i wanted to change
they disciplined me to the point where
change occurred to me i i became smarter
i became stronger i became healthier
um cleaner
more focused
and
ever since i got released from there
it's just
i didn't know what i went back to the
same route with no discipline no
structure and it actually still with me
as i grow this is why i
i really lack a lot of um
any kind of support unless it's
with law enforcement or
or military type um kind of individuals
uh you know
individuals that are there are
homeowners and private citizens
i mean these are the people that i
really looked up for
even it was only for 90 days it sounds
like it's a discipline that you longed
for
it's discipline that i long for is
discipline that i urge for
um because you connect that discipline
as being loved absolutely uh i i i
connected the discipline from the drill
instructors of forcing me to shine my
boots to the point where i could see my
face on my toe uh forcing me to crease
my uniforms all over again because it
was just a half an inch off
or ripping off the iris pendants on your
button-down shirts that the military or
up individuals normally call and
describe that in their bases
um learning how to wake up at 5 30
getting yelled at as a
sorry [ __ ] bird do it again you know
it through throughout all that
deep down inside
i knew he loved me
i knew that person cared for me
that's what made me continue thinking
about these people
um and it's it's always the truth when
they say that you know we're not gonna
follow you when you go home
you know the test starts the first the
first day of the test actually starts
when you're home
because you're not gonna have a drill
instructor or di in the train station
every five seconds when you're wrong
and then sometimes i just wish that i
never i never left from there
sometimes and i found myself going to
jail on purpose and violating parole
because i just couldn't manage
out here and i knew automatically
they're not going to send me to the
regular prison where there's no care
but they're going to send me back to
this intensive military
uh boot camp for another 90 days
and um
which we actually look forward to i
looked forward six times
six times
to the point where they told me dude
you're this is not normal like you have
to stop coming
you're literally wilder man now cause i
was in willard drug treatment campus in
romulus new york
so your agoraphobia started at what
point
my agoraphobia the phobia yes um it
started to the point where um
as a child i mean every time i i feel
like i i go out i find myself in either
wrong crowds where i used to be
previously
um
or when i go and try to communicate with
family or even try to get some kind of
support or some kind of startup where i
can continue mine
i found i found myself being betrayed or
alone or back turned and then that fears
me inside because
as much as a bad like crime that i
committed for selling drugs to
undercover cop when i was a child those
people at the boot camp they never
judged me they never turned their backs
on me
as many times i screwed up they were
constantly there on me dedicating and
this is what made me change this is why
i have not been in prison for over 20
years right
but now the lifestyle you're leading
today is
it's it's pretty much the same lifestyle
i've been i'm
not the same lifestyle i'm living at 13
years old as far as the breaking the law
but the same lifestyle i'm living as 13
years old with no kind of support no
trust for
society in the streets so describe your
existence today you you told me you
haven't been out of your apartment i
have i don't go out my house no more um
since the pandemic um today is your
first day out of the house for in two
years you said
i'm not going to say the first time out
completely but i do run dogs i i i i end
up running the dog business through
rover.com and i found that i am great at
what i do um so there are times that i
do i do step on my house to walk a dog
or two for just about five to ten
minutes around my block and then go back
up um as far as the dogs if i if i don't
have a person at my house where i'm um
renting a room at right now the roommate
and i asked her son if he wants to make
10 or 15 bucks i'll offer him that so he
can take the dolls because i really
don't want to go out because i'm so used
to being in a house but if no one wants
to do i have to maintain my
professionality and put my mental weight
my mental state of mind
somewhere far away because this is the
only thing i have left and no one gave
it to me but myself and the people that
gave me this discipline to make me
change when i was in boot camp
so you have a roommate now yeah i have a
roommate which is not a good
relationship either you know i'm so
again
i'm 35 i've been finding myself house to
house i traveled to california got
stranded out there i lived in the state
of vermont and st albans for about a
year
i lived in chesterfield new jersey uh
between crosswix and bordentown new
jersey for about a year and a half
pennsylvania new york
and i just
i end up coming back because i either
get stuck or stranded and i don't know
how to communicate to find a support
system in the beginning where i can
start maintaining myself but do you have
like a social life just even if it's
just with your roommate i don't even
socialize with my roommate at all
because again um i we try to communicate
but i guess i don't know how to
communicate with people no more
so the i i try to avoid any type of
altercation or any misunderstandings
whether it's a roommate or out people
outside or even people in the store so
you just stay in your room and that's it
i even do my food shopping through
amazon fresh
every single month of if i need clothes
sneakers i'll order if i need my laundry
washings i don't have a washing machine
in my house there's a laundry downstairs
they come upstairs to pick up my laundry
and i paid them for a folding wash
anything i could if i had no choice but
to go out then i'll go out as quick as
possible and pray to god that nothing
happens because
i don't know how to communicate well
with someone that comes to me very
violent and unfortunate where i live in
the neighborhood it's just getting worse
because everyone seems to be going crazy
but everyone doesn't have the capability
of me of maintaining it but you're
communicating well with me right now
you see because i have to because
i
i
i want my video
and my mental health awareness to be out
there i communicate with my pet owners
very professionally i make them feel
very comfortable and trustworthy to me i
have a talent i have experience of of
learning to be a part of society
but i don't have the power to convince
someone to give me an opportunity
as much as i keep on showing like i just
showed you now that i'm communicating
very well with you and it feels good to
hear it every time
but that's all i get
then they forget about and then i'm back
alone
and my dogs that's why i always just
take care of dogs because have you hit
girlfriends or anything like that i had
girlfriends but
i didn't learn how to
um
again when i was 13
and i committed that
uh my mind my mother signed custody over
to my ex-girlfriend because she was 34
and i was 14.
turning 14.
so from 14 years old to
pretty much
a few years ago from my lex my last
ex-girlfriend
they all have been older woman's um i
don't know maybe it's because of the
lack of my mom
uh
i was 14 with my first one she was 34 or
36 30 36
yeah i was 14 she was 36 we broke up
when i turned 17 and she turned 39
and then after that i went to with some
other lady in the bronx named mina lisa
she was 46 and i was just coming out of
boot camp at 19 years old and then just
two years ago i broke up with my
ex-girlfriend marie she's 43
but you know i'm 33 when i broke up with
her you know i'm 35. like older women or
older women like you
i guess i was um
i must say i was attractive to older
women since the child
um
i don't know us
and again i was i was a child
trying to act like a man being
agoraphobic you might have a hard time
approaching a woman who's
who's who's my age
right it might be appropriate for me
right and i didn't know
and i didn't know that was wrong because
my family used to tell me hey man find a
girl your age
you know but you know our relationship i
mean who are you to tell me this now
when you couldn't tell me anything even
when i was doing good you know so i
didn't really take advice from them as
far as my relationship i just did what i
wanted to do but something deep down
inside of me always thought about that
that girl my age
where i you know like i have a baby and
a family and grow old together you know
obviously unfortunately you can't do
that with a woman that's 23 years older
than you
are you lonely
i'm huh living this lifestyle are you
lonely i'm extremely lonely and um
the only thing that doesn't make me
lonely is my dogs
um to tell you the truth you know even
if i abort them for for four nights or
just one night you know it it makes up
for all the loneliness that i went
through for the last two three weeks or
months you know so i try to
fill my schedule up with as much as dog
boardings or dog walks as possible and
as at that moment i have to either go
outside or do a meet agree with the pet
owners and the pet to see if it's a good
fit or nine times an attendant i'll tell
them to come to my home does it make you
uncomfortable to even do those meetings
it would make me uncomfortable and
there's no dogs around but i'd normally
use the dog as like my technique to get
a way of not communicating
professionally with people since i lack
social attention on the dog
so they love when i make my jokes how
high i be
my baby you know so they like the jokey
um you know it makes them feel
comfortable when they're taking business
trips to chicago or california
absolutely absolutely and then when
they're home and they leave and their
dog is by themselves with a person that
they totally don't know and they just
met online
and they come back to pick them up and
then they rebook you like they did
for friday again
it feels awesome
it feels like the best thing in the
world
and this is just a dog
um
a business
that's making me feel like that
so imagine what more i can't imagine
what more is out there
that can make me feel
much more alive than what i'm already
trying to feel yeah it sounds like it's
just you just long for love right i mean
i feel like i lost the way of
communicating
because again it plays a whole of you
you know
i i i i like to consider myself very
communicative individual
but unfortunately i've been secluded for
quite a few years with just minimum
access to go outside voluntarily
so the communicating i guess slacked off
you know so i don't really
you know not interacting with other
right but i don't think i'm a bad person
or a criminal because of that
or i should be
neglected makes you makes you
uncomfortable to
go to a restaurant with lots of people
it does
it even gets me uncomfortable taking the
train right here yeah i was surprised
that you were willing to come out here
it really was so i you know
i messed up and put my air my ear pods
on and and pretend i'm sleeping and
knowing that i'm not sleeping i don't
know it's something in new york city
when people doesn't want to you're doing
a great job you're doing a great job
when they don't want to see anyone they
just pretend they're sleeping you know
just until they're stopped but you know
what would you say is your biggest fear
my biggest fear is
it's dying alone
my biggest fear is growing old alone
um
i always think about having kids
but um that's just one thing that i
learned again this is why i really
appreciate the
the places that i end up going when i
made a mistake in my life like boot camp
because um if it wasn't for this place i
would have never graduated from school i
would have never had enough um
um
patience and
and self-discipline to know that i'm not
ready for a child to know that um this
is gonna lead to consequences if i make
this choice so this this place i always
grateful for
but i am very fair of
of being growing old alone with with
with not leaving a child in this world
as something part of minds you know
where
but i just never
was good to in relationship field where
i can find
or be or feel like i'll be accepted
because you know
the other 35 year old guy
doesn't have a criminal record
and probably has super career and super
money and guarantee security for a wife
and this is the things i cannot promise
you know do you feel like you were loved
when you were a child
uh when i was a child that was pretty
much like the brett had a step child so
what people calls it's why i decided to
run away from pennsylvania i just
couldn't take that uh abuse no more i
was physically abused by my father when
i was a kid
i was verbally and sometimes physically
abused by my stepmother
and let's not mention my stepbrothers
and stepsister
that i was also physically abused about
so
i really didn't have
love in my home
growing up but just um
pretty much acceptance because you know
i have to be there
you know when everyone goes school
shopping and gets the new boss where i
grew up at or the new reeboks
i always found myself getting the second
down hand-me-downs
of my step siblings that are not using
it no more
when the xbox 360 came out uh i was
always getting the sega genesis and the
nintendo regular
you know
so i mean i don't really call that love
you know but just
acceptance
because they have to be here you know i
have to be there
you know
what emotions do you go through
i've been going through a lot of
uh lonely emotions i've been going
through a lot of anger emotions
um extreme stress where where i've
checked my iphone on the hardify app and
whoo my stress level is
up there 90 something
you know so when i see stuff like that i
try to maintain
my levels more much downer on whatever i
do
whether it's uh
playing uh country music that i like to
hear
you know
and put it down so i don't be judged by
my neighbors like what is this guy
hearing you know
um or
i'll just probably put like a show or
lose myself in tic tac
or
reach out to pet owners and see if they
need my assistance anything to just try
to keep distracted from the feelings
that i'll be feeling when i'm alone
you know and not loved
and like i said it's okay i've been
learning to deal with that
for quite a while where i'm really used
to it but i know that there's more of me
just being locked away
like i'm a really really bad person
you know i know people make mistakes but
there should be some time
for that i find myself even trying want
to go to ukraine and fight
because the army don't want to let me
have a chance in our own country because
of what happened
start 20 years ago
you know so this is what what stresses
out so much
whether you go to school or graduate or
complete and did a whole 360 degree
change and decades pass unfortunately it
will still pop up
so then you you ask yourself what's left
if this is all that i have
what the 20 years passed and another 20
more years passed and we're at 40 years
what's really there
what's the purpose of asking and telling
people to change to stop make mistakes
to don't do that to change your life and
do everything
if they're still gonna deny
whatever progress whatever
accomplishments you have made for over
two decades
they'll still always be there
permanently into the day you die
and a lot of people can't take that out
here fortunately
i was one of those people that couldn't
take that unfortunately
but i learned what happens when you
can't take that and you lose your cool
i've seen the hands-on they don't care
they'll violate you
take you back to prison
put all sorts of names in the news of
he's passed bad criminal long sheet of
record
forget about the changes and sacrifices
that we've been trying to make that i've
been trying to make they don't want to
hear none of that they just put in this
bad thing but i learned that this is not
the way to go to keep on
holding composure even if you don't know
how to socialize with people
even if you have still mixed emotions
from your childhood at 13 and you're now
35
you still have to not give them what
they want whoever they are and i'm not
just
saying one agency i mean unfortunately
we're dealing with corruption in this
country and there's no joke there's no
way of hiding and i don't need proof i
mean the proof is out there every single
day on the media donald trump's raid
yesterday everything
and we just need people to start taking
taking these steps to save our
environment
to save our people
because everyone that out there aren't
really violent they're not really evil
they just are losing
their mind
like i'm supposed to be losing my mind
but i i learned not to
they have it
and if we could learn to work together
maybe people will actually help us this
is what i think and if not then i'll go
back home
and lock myself in my little cubicle
room and watch my furry friends
but i know that's the work that's the
only way
i've been doing that way i'm trying to
search if there's any other way out have
you ever seen a therapist
i tried in the past but again this is
where i say the system is systematically
corrupted
uh
i've been open with therapists
psychologists years ago i even tried to
take their advices and get on medication
like prozac
i i stopped all that
i realized
i don't need that to communicate well
like you mentioned earlier that i
communicate well i'm not on medication
and i haven't seen the therapist for
quite a while
so i tried my best to give to giving me
my own medicine
whatever it is self-discipline uh
motivation in my head i try myself to
get my own therapy
or even look up random 100 numbers just
to speak and ventilate because um
the things that i try to go on therapy
they they still look at you like a crazy
cuckoo a 7 30
you know he needs this and we need to
hold him now by force
just because you mentioned either not
want to kill yourself but what's the
point of living
the same thing i'm mentioning now
and because of that they hold you
against your will
they have to put in those paper words
this is what my brain tells me from
everything i've been exposed on the news
on social media on everything even
outside the neighborhoods
that paperwork goes to the uppers
the money comes in
you know
the uh trillion dollar uh rescue plans
that's all that's divided to
psychologists to police departments
to supreme courts
to social services
but we never see any of help
the only ones i've seen that are getting
that is the workers
police officer driving 2021
mercedes-benz
social service workers and welfare
making a hundred and one thousand
dollars a year
that is not good with me
it's not
it's not fair
because if they're getting 101 000 why
are we still dealing with the same exact
problem before the hundred and one
thousand you got paid
so this is what shows me that no one
cares
the city is overwhelmed with so many by
the books they just turned into numbers
they are no longer humans
we're a number
now call in
pa1583 that's welfare
let's go to department corrections
inmate zero seven eight one five eight
three report
let's go to criminal court to save a
traffic violation now we're calling
traffic number one five eight three
that's two thousand four
what happened to our
identity
what happened to our human
rights
where did it go
so this is why again i lock myself away
from society
without being violent
without breaking the law
without anything
without a career
but i'm healthy i'm not sick
i have never tested positive for
coronavirus
i have never tasted positive for monkey
pox
sexual transmitted diseases
anything whatsoever
so we literally have just a human being
wasted
because no acceptance
you know and this is why i just
say okay let me step away
you know because i know where this leads
to
it's just gonna lead to more
no no no you can't you can't and people
can't take that denied every single day
for years
this is why i started feeling like why
are they treating me like a committed
murderer
or i committed some kind of sexual act
of a crime
or some type of domestic violence
crime
i was a child when i made this mistake a
child
[Music]
it's not like i got arrested for selling
drugs two years ago or when i was 21
i was 15 turning 16 years old
when they finally charged me for that
i'm 35 years old right now
i have a lot of people out there that
loves me because the work i provide and
the trust i provide for their pets
i know how to pick up grocery bags from
old ladies that live in my building
across the street
after i'm telling nypd get the hell out
of here you're not gonna do nothing
about it
you're just sitting there on your phone
and you're arresting someone on their
phone that doesn't make sense
this is this is this is where i feel
like god told me i have to come here to
fight
this is what i tell my russian friend i
met on tick tock too as well i cannot
leave so i was going to north dakota and
run away from new york city to escape
this and start a new life over there
okay because i was planning to go to
north dakota
the capital too um
but something told me to stay here i had
to fight
not physically
illegally fight i'll talk about legal
fight
i don't care how hot it is outside i
want to go out i want to protest i want
to legally protest i want to legally put
everything out there
peacefully safe
until until something is being done this
is where i live at
you know i shouldn't have to run away to
a different state
because nothing's good going good in my
state and i fear running away from state
because we deal with races every single
day still
and you know half of these places out
there
again north dakota is 89 caucasians 3
african americans and two percent
different races all the way from native
americans in spanish
i don't know if they'll be accepted over
there
and that's 1600 miles away that's a
two-day trip on amtrak i did all my
research trust me because i'm really
serious about it so this is what holds
me back too is like will i be accepted
why why vanish
you know i don't have family friends out
there but wow how beautiful those houses
look
wow how safari and siri says that
everyone in north dakota are so nice and
they welcome you
wow how all this sounds so good but is
it safe for a spanish person like me
from new york city
that has a history from you know my
felony from the 20
and this is one made me never leave
when i do want to leave so i just say
it's either that or stay here and fight
and fight and just keep fighting like
you've been doing joel
can't do nothing else take care of your
dogs and keep fighting and hopefully one
day someone
someone finally say hey man enough is
enough we need to help these people out
you know we need to find out their
stories is valid
uh research it confirm it
but we cannot continue ignoring these
people
because if we do then what's the point
of having them still living in this
society
there's nothing else you know
and i want to grow up to be able to
interact with people again i miss people
especially the good people that like my
dog pet owners that appreciates me even
appreciating my low rates because god
knows i need the money obviously i don't
have a career
but for some reason i don't charge 75 a
night like
hundreds of people on on the app do
that has hundreds of reviews i only have
nine reviews
yeah i'm still charging 38
it's not about the money for me it's
about
acceptance it's about connecting
that's worth more than money for me
all right
joel thank you so much for sharing your
story
thank you sir i wish you the best of
luck thank you very much you're working
up against
thank you thank you
you